est-ce qu'on peut tenir à au film de
louis malle ou es ce que vous avez un
autre film pas vendre le nom est ce
qu'il faut que je dise que ce film est
enfin je le répète est le premier film
de louis malle qui a froid 25 ans qui a
été l'assistant si je me trompe ou
m'arrêter je suis pas un rugby aussi
l'homme qui a été là non je me trompe il
n'a pas été là 6 6 2 aux commandes du
silence qu'il a été fusillé si c'est le
cas il faut le souligner je voudrais
dire aussi en part en passant j'ai vu
sans un article l'autre jour je ne pense
que ça doit être vrai que l'assistant de
louis malle pour ce film était le même
que l'assistante bresson louis malle a
été assistant quelques temps sur le film
devrait sans le condamner à mort s'est
échappé aux é jours il avait remplacé
estimé qu'ils avaient suffisamment
appris et il a pris comme assistant dans
son propre film le garçon qui jouait le
rôle du condamné à mme leterrier
françois le terrain comme second
assistant comme second raciste voilà la
vérité historique
je crois avoir compris mais je crois je
m'en souviendrai plus enfin je vous
écouterai j'écouterai bien qui veut
parler de ce film grand premier ballon
celui je crois que le film était
beaucoup plus intéressant par là la
personnalité du garçon que l'on devine à
travers le film que par le film lui-même
qui effectivement n'est pas n'est pas
une n'est pas une complète une complète
réussite mais la façon d'en mal à
traiter son sujet étant donné surtout
que c'est un premier film ya tellement
de jeunes réalisateurs qui essaie de
faire du tape-à-l'oeil qu'est cette
herbe l'esbrouffe
il aurait pu il aurait pu faire beaucoup
de choses avec ce film il a refusé
toutes les facilités il a il a vraiment
essayé surtout dans des stands et dans
les scènes qui sont à peu près du fait
greffer nous greffer sur le sujet
principal parce que sujet principal est
tellement mauvais qu'il a été obligé de
l'éviter et justement dans toutes ces
scènes qui ne sont pas capital
c'est là où il sait où il s'est laissé
aller et c'est là où son talent
se voir le mieux plan d'eau rien je
crois qu'il ya une confusion entre
toujours de textes de ce film il ya deux
textes est d'abord le roman qui est à
l'origine du film ne remonterons de noël
khalef que j'ai pas lu du reste épais
lors il ya le scénario tel qu'il est
devenu
alors là moi je ne partage absolument
pas votre sévérité à tous surtout à
cause des dialogues d'euros génie mais
vous n'avez pas nommer qui me paraissent
mois d'une qualité tout à fait
exceptionnel tout à fait keystone elle
est très rare surtout il faut pas
oublier que l'une des grandes
admirations de louis malle et bressan
mais l'autre et jacques tati et je crois
qu'il a retenu cette leçon de silence
non pas du monde du silence de cousteau
mais des films de tati ou qui était très
bredouille et plus ou moins
volontairement peut-être qu'il y avait
aussi des affections technique mais
d'anti retirer en tout cas beaucoup de
efficacement que très saisissant alors
dans les silences dans les blancs
d'ascenseur pour l'échafaud dans tous
les fragments de dialogues qui sont
volés dans la rue rien au hasard
ap dans les bars absurde dans la seine
au jeune âge fait dans la première c'est
nous ou la petite fleuriste et son jeune
amant sont sur le pas de la du magasin
de fleurs
il ya un dialogue qui ne veut absolument
rien dire et qui est appelé mon meirieu
comme et des loques de la ville
de même le type le plaisantin qui part
de la dauphine l'euro qui continue of
sont exactement il ya toute une partie
de dialogue de nîmes est très classique
avec des mots durs excellent démocrate
et moulante heures les mots d'auteurs
très bon jean charolles qui vous avait
été le premier je crois à parler à cette
tribune du film de louis malle quand le
prix louis delluc lui a été décerné est
ce que vous êtes d'accord est ce qu'on
vient de dire oui et non c'est à dire
que le l'ascenseur pour l'échafaud
apposé incontestablement un problème de
conscience pour un certain nombre des
membres du jury du prix de lui car c'est
un film qui à la base par d'une
concession formel il est évident que jeu
de jantes huiliers le producteur et de
louis malle qui a travaillé avec bresso
est avec cousteau on espérait qu'il
viserait plus haut elle espérait qu'il
ne partirait pas d'un fort engagement
série noire alors ils ont créé toutes
sortes de précautions il multipliait les
rideaux de fumée
ils ont engagé rogine signé pour écrire
des dialogues sur lesquelles je ne
partage pas l'optimisme de paul mauriac
mais il n'en reste pas moins que le
sujet est incontestablement un faux
roman policier américain
eh bien je pense que thuillier qui est
le producteur d'un condamné à mort s'est
échappée aurait dû jouer sur marne
comme il a joué sur bresso louis malle a
su admirablement choisir ses comédiens
il est certain que tout ce que je peux
vous dire en théorie la gare aux tous
sont tous sont très bien choisi mais
pour les diriger à mon sens il lui en a
souvent échappé
jeanne moreau lui échapper en le bon
sens d'autres ont échappé dans le
mauvais sens
vous semble-t-il et alors on parle
mentale en parle du talent de jeanne
moreau et il faut bien dire que jeanne
moreau apparaît jeu dans ce qu'il paraît
être moi le meilleur moment du film
c'est à dire cet espace go notre de
promenade désespérer de jeanne moreau à
travers paris est un très grand morceau
de cinéma et vous oubliez maurice ronet
vraiment très beau mais c'est vraiment
son premier bon rôle
pardon de rendez vous de juillet qui
était son premier film il était déjà
très remuant il était d'un rendez-vous
de vie mais je pense que c'est là où il
a débuté
vous ne voyez rien tracé s'il ya la
partition il ya la partition musicale
qui est truqué mills un avis qui est un
solo de trompette et qui je fais bonne
idée alors visé improvisé selon les sur
les images étant donné que d'avis la fel
improvisé en asie thorium le film étant
projeté muet et que je trouve que je
crois ajoute beaucoup plus beaux moments
pathétiques du film c'était le système
calendrier vadim dans sept ans jamais
c'est plutôt et cereus est plus réussie
me semble que dans cet enjeu mais est ce
que dans le camp jamais le
l'improvisation était totale je ne crois
pas je vois mal angola il faut souligner
que mal à profiter de la présence très
brave à paris 2006 pour lui projeté le
film à lui assez à ses quatre musiciens
et ils ont vraiment improvisé sur le vif
sans aucune préparation
il n'y a pas un spectateur de cette
salle on est bien ici l'ascenseur je
trouve très très mauvais oui je trouve
des dialogues très très fort minique
parle absolument faux ce qu'il disait
phone n'a aucun rapport avec la réalité
mais ça c'est pas du tout cela je
voulais vous parler
je ne vois pas pourquoi les critiques
n'ont pas parlé du film de guy roux qui
précède et qui est forte
c'était la tribune des critiques de
cinéma avec jean de baroncelli georges
charensol jacques doniol valcroze et
claude mauriac dans notre rubrique le
visage de la semaine voici le metteur en
scène louis malle
[Applaudissements]
alors oui mal était dans la salle et si
vous avez envie de répondre à certaines
des critiques qui ont été émises vous à
vous pouvez répondre sinon nous parlons
d'autre chose simplement une petite
rectification à faire je n'ai pas quitté
le plateau de bois sombre parce que
j'estimais que jean cédras cg pour
boisson la plus grande admiration mais
j'estime simplement qu'on apprend rien
comme assistance et c'est un point de
vue qui m'est personnelle par ailleurs
je veux dire que j'ai été membre du jury
du prix delluc je ne serai pas donné le
prix c'est un premier film et laurier
d'années à qui je vais peut-être faire
hurler les gens mais je leur ai donné à
vadim
[Applaudissements]
et comme si vous voulez mon avis la
seule morale qu'on peut tirer de mon
film c'est comédie bresson qui est venu
le voir très gentiment bien qu'ils
détestent le cinéma revendeurs du sien
il est venu me voir il m'a dit sans
faire de reproches et sans me faire de
compliments il m'a dit c'est très
difficile de faire un premier film il
m'a serré la main il est parti et voilà
je crois que je demande qu'on me juge
sur vingt films et pas sur ce film ceci
dit je voudrais ajouter encore une chose
c'est que je défendrai toujours mon
sujet d'abord parce que c'est moi qui
l'ait choisi puisque assez malhonnête de
dire de jouer aux jeunes réalisateurs
martyrs à qui on a imposé un sujet qu'il
a pu je ne veux pas du tout le faire
s'est il ya des choses qui me plaisent
infiniment dans le sujet c'est un film
qui n'est enfin le film l'est peut-être
mais le sujet n'était pas vulgaire ce
qui est assez rare dans les situations
qu'on leur fait ce mot est ignoble qu'on
appelle le suspense quand vous
évidemment qui plaît infiniment
paraît-il au public
mais ce suspense était assez curieux
c'est amusant de piste un exercice
amusant de traiter un personnage enfermé
dans un ascenseur enfin moi ça m'a amusé
et j'espère que ça vous amusera aussi ce
que j'ai remarqué que les critiques
n'ont pas dit et georges lair faire
remarquer nous en avons parlé ce matin
au téléphone c'est que vous avez utilisé
pour les rôles secondaires des acteurs
convaincants général rarement au cinéma
des gens comme gérard darrieux comme
hubert deschamps je trouve absolument
excellent et des merveilles on voit
jamais aussi des missions il est génial
il n' y arriver on le sait depuis dix
ans et personnelle faite mais les
producteurs ne le savent pas mais non je
vais vous poser une question là pour
revenir au cinéma pur dans la fameuse
dans la grande scène dans la promenade
des chances si j'ose dire les champs
elysées jeanne moreau comment avez-vous
dit river jeanne moreau lahaye vous
dirigent ou là et vous laisser aller à
je m'insurge contre ce qu'on a dit que
contre les pats mes acteurs voyez-vous
garanties qui n'ont rien fait dans une
soie responsable bon je vais vous faire
dire parce que tout à l'heure il ya eu
quelques uns je ne sais pas qui dans la
tribune qui a dit aux beaux jeunes gros
à la flèche que l'a voulu comme elle a
du génie ça prendra des merveilleuses
j'ai senti au contraire que tout ça
était minutieusement fait que trop c'est
trop
je veux leurs proches mais ça je vous
assure que moi la direction d'acteur
c'est la seule chose qui m'amuse et qui
m'intéresse c'est pour le moins vite
très très loin suivez c'est une certaine
façon de communiquer avec les gens c'est
très merveilleux est ce qu'on peut vous
demander est ce que vous pouvez répondre
à cette question entre les projets qui
vous qui vous sont offertes actuellement
est-ce que vous avez déjà quelques
préférences lorsque vous voyez ce que va
avait tourné je m'assure un peu parce
que les producteurs me font venir comme
je suis tout beau tout nouveau vous
savez à l'opposé tas de trucs
oui ça durera probablement pas et on en
fait venir et on me dit voilà nous
allons faire un film au mois de mai nous
avons acheté tel sujet en général le
sujet est détestable il faut bien le
dire mais il est acheté mais il est
d'acheter donc il faut le faire nous
avons pensé à tel acteur qui va se
trouver libre commence à tourner le 1er
mai il va se trouver libre le 28 avril
nous avons pensé à tel dialogue est ce
que nous avons déjà contacté qui
commencent à travailler alors je prends
mon chapeau que j'ai pas de chapeau mais
je m'en vais c'est pas possible comme
moi j'aimerais que les producteurs me
fasse venir me dise voilà nous trouvons
que nous aimons bien votre film nous ne
l'aimons pas mais nous pensons que
peut-être vous ferez votre prochain film
sera bon et donc c'est là qu'est ce que
vous le referiez est-ce que vous avez un
sujet un plan quinquennal
vous avez parlé d'un
d'une nouvelle de vivant denon point de
lendemain qui est un conte libertins du
xviiie oui je vais le faire je prends je
me répète si dans le public à une
question est ce qu'on voudrait vous
posez attendait on attendait pas tant on
peut approcher parce que mon fils n'ira
pas plus loin
je n'ai pas compris pourquoi la petite
fille ramasser la corde à l'extérieur
puisque la corde était toujours attaché
beaucoup on nous faisait un grand
reproche
en ce qui concerne et enfin on faisait
des grands projets en ce qui concerne la
conclusion du film 10 ans on ne peut pas
condamner le personnage que joue jamais
on ne peut pas le condamner puisqu'il
n'y a pas d'évidence il faut donc que
cette que sept
c'est le reproche qu'on fait
actuellement
mais si j'avais supprimé le vol de la
corde il est encore bien enfin coûté
n'ont cependant c'est pas possible il
n'y a pas moins qu'elle s'est retourné
des cauchemars est une autre question
pourquoi pourquoi vous avez choisi ce
scénario-là ce roman un goût des traits
france mais je vais vous donner un
exemple d'un raisonnement je me fais un
producteur je lui en veux pas du tout
son raisonnement est très sain si vous
voulez j'avais proposé un sujet qui
était de moi qui étais une histoire qui
me c'était un sujet assez balzacien
c'était l'histoire d'une réussite à
paris en 1956 et 36
c'était amusant à traiter les
personnages sont amusants va y avait des
choses il nous y voilà il a réfléchi
pendant quinze jours il m'a fait venir
il m'a dit vous comprenez on prend un
triple risque on prendrait sur vous
parce que c'est votre premier film et il
est certain que c'est un risque énorme
c'est que quand on fait son premier film
on n'en dort pas la nuit
c'est ça on est vraiment c'est très très
risqué parce que si c'est si ça marche
pas c'est une catastrophe pour tout le
monde à commencer par vous deuxièmement
on croirait sur le scénario là j'étais
pas d'accord je crois que le scénario
était de me paraissait aussi commercial
possible puisqu'ils me paraissait bon et
troisièmement pareil sur les acteurs
puisque c'était un personnage qui avait
18 ans ou 20 ans et donc il ne pouvait
pas y avoir ni gérard philipe ni daniel
gélin ni courtier aurel
comprenez
alors ils m'ont dit ce trek losc est
impossible on veut bien prendre un
risque sur trois mais pas trois sur
trois pas possible et ça ça m'a
convaincu
on va poser une dernière question mais
je savais que le temps presse
croyez vous monsieur mal que vous vous
avez été forcé de choisir un scénario
qui vous était un peu imposée qui vous
qui vous paraissait déjà commercial
croyez-vous que devant le succès que
vous avez l'esprit de l'ue croyez-vous
pourrait en sortir que vous pourrez
faire quelque chose qu'il vous plaît vh
chaos garantie mais j'en sortirai non
mais on peut faire un effet une remarque
à ce soit ce sujet je trouve en effet
que la question de ce spectateur est
intéressant le cinéma français n'a
jusqu'à présent pas donné de films
comparable au point de vue insolite
prendre à certains films suédois ou
mexicains ou italiens hongrois ou même
argent mais vous je m'adore est ce que
vous croyez que vous pourrez créer car
je vous interromps ne croyons des pôles
insolites et l'exotisme
il ya des sujets qui nous paraissent
merveilleusement un solide parce qu'ils
viennent d'ailleurs
ça s'appelle même pour les cheveux pour
les fourrages même pas le cinéma
français
vraiment je le dis franchement je n'aime
pas les cinémas français vraiment je
n'ai pas un film sur sur 20 ou 30
conférence oif et je vous assure je vous
assure que par exemple dans le plaisir
que nous avons au cinéma américain il ya
vraiment une part d'exane sur oui bien
sûr ça on ne le dit pas assez parce que
sur ses coûts je suis loin pour le
cinéma italien on les dit des bêtises
aussi sur le néo réalisme quand même oui
mais regardez certains passionnés vous
avez des acteurs que nous trouvons
merveilleux et qui sont les balles pétré
où les robes vert de l'italie par
exemple on comprenait et et je vous
assure que je suis persuadé que rob
verrait bel petra au mexique paraissent
vraiment tellement français tellement
insolite chose que vous dire que tous
les intellectuels américains vont voir
les films de fernandel et m'ont tous dit
mais fernand des nous ne ratons pas de
ses filles
tout là tous les intellectuels
l'avant-garde mais bon il faudra il faut
peut-être italien pour s'élever à savoir
que jouer ta machine est la plus grande
cave au que la terre ait jamais on
remercie beaucoup louis malle de d'être
venu à cette tribu alors je donne rendez
vous en novembre prochain
décembre prochain joyon avant avant bien
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]